what's going on everyone it is axl beats
here for anime uproar and recently we
did a video covering the phantom troupe
of hunter hunter and since you guys seem
to enjoy that so much today we'll be
ranking what i consider to be the 20
best net abilities in the series
if you enjoy this video and you want to
see more hunter hunter content on this
channel remember to leave a like as well
as a comment down below it only takes a
second but it really does help with the
youtube algorithm and of course if you
haven't subscribed to anime uproar make
this the video that you do by clicking
that bell and selecting all
notifications you can also follow anime
uproar on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar or you can follow myself at
excellionyt finally this video will
contain spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned so off the
bat we need to set some ground rules nen
is nothing if not varied and as such it
can be kind of difficult to compare
something that can be used purely to
play dodgeball
or to create a giant bodhisattva nen is
very fluid versatile and creative so
judging it purely based on destructive
power doesn't really paint a good
picture in my opinion
in general though i'm going to try and
make the list based on a couple of
things yes partly how strong it is but
i'm going to include how versatile and
usable it is as well something like
razer's 14 devils or komugi's evolving
gungi skills
are totally great in their own rights
but how useful are they in general
situations that's something i'm going to
try and think about secondly i'm only
allowing one ability per character on
this list so for example if biscuit's
magical spa is on here then her body
transformation cannot be and of course
i'm going to be talking about the
abilities themselves not the characters
although if it does suit the character
very well that's a bonus but if you
would like to see me ranking nen users
specifically let us know in the comments
and i'll try and talk animak and gozan
into it now before we get into the
actual video though i do want to cover
some honorable mentions as well as
explaining why they didn't make the cut
firstly one that's probably going to
upset a few people because it's a main
character ability let's talk about
gone's transformation by giving up his
ability to use men in the future as well
as much of his life energy gon was able
to summon all of the power he will
eventually have and grow in age while
this is nearly god tier powerful for a
short time it also comes at such a huge
cost
anything that can only be used once and
then turns off then forever in this
series specifically is definitely gonna
lose some points not to mention gon
falls into a coma that would have killed
him without life support and nanika's
intervention despite this being a fan
favorite ability it just has too many
drawbacks that are way too serious
kilo's god speed is another one by
allowing his nen to manipulate his
movement kiluah gains a ton of speed
basically this works in two parts
firstly his nen will force his muscles
to move to dodge incoming attacks and
react to them and second he has more
active control over it to gain
lightning speed the electricity shooting
off his aura will also shock or even
burn his opponents or allah as if he's
carrying them to some degree now this
all seems great but the downside of
hillary's ability comes in the amount of
aura he has kilowatt just doesn't have a
huge supply and this trains him a lot
these issues combined means that he can
only use this very briefly and it can
kinda just end unexpectedly leaving him
open this is a great technique but much
like gones this is just a very all or
nothing move sure it doesn't put him in
a coma but if this doesn't do the job
he's kinda screwed pito is another fan
favorite character and while their nen
abilities are pretty useful they all
kind of fall flat in some places dr
blyth allows pito to perform surgery on
someone to heal them however it isn't
really a quick process and blight
themselves is immobile and tied to
pito's tail meaning they have to stay in
a pretty small area for the entirety of
its use she can also attach life to a
person to control them even being able
to force them to speak or use nen
finally pito can use puppet master
serenity to essentially use puppeteering
on themselves raising their offensive
abilities in general while all of these
are fairly solid there are just better
versions of each of these present in
many of the characters throughout the
list so as a package sure it's great but
individually it's just kind of a jack of
all trades and master of none kind of
thing our final honorable mention is
manga based with camilla's cat who lived
a million times this is an ability i
find to be both incredibly interesting
and useful but it's so situational that
it just can't really make the list
in the event that camilla is killed a
nen cat will appear behind the one who
killed her and completely obliterate the
murderer stealing their life force and
then feeding it back to camilla this
will revive her and heal her to some
degree but again only if she actually
dies more specifically if she is killed
she could be tortured beaten and left on
the verge of death and her nan would do
nothing it's this limitation that really
stops her from being super effective and
it stops her from being on this actual
list
but with that said let's get on to our
real entries so starting off the list at
number 20 we have something which might
be a little bit weird to some people but
i'm choosing biscuits magical spa
services
while this obviously isn't the strongest
combat oriented ability it is easily one
of the most useful abilities in the
series biscuit summons a masseuse named
cookie who's able to revitalize people
stop their fatigue heal minor diseases
like arthritis and burn off fat it can
even give you a massage that changes the
effect of 30 minutes of sleep into
feeling like 8 hours this is genuinely
very useful just in day to day life but
in a more effective and practical way
it's also very useful for intensive
training which is how we see biscuit
using it throughout the series
yes this isn't useful in a fight but i
think all the benefits that this offers
more than makes up for that in 19th
place we have another kind of supportive
ability with machi's nen stitches this
is another one that's kind of oriented
towards healing and it's just insanely
powerful using threads made of men machi
can sew up injuries much like normal
stitches however the healing properties
are so much stronger even in cases where
people's arms have been entirely cut off
machi can still sew them back on and the
newly reattached limb is functional
immediately and i just think that
anything that can reattach a missing
limb is probably pretty phenomenal while
it's not being taken into consideration
for this specific ability she can also
use these threads more offensively to
capture opponents or manipulate them
whether you want to consider that in the
stitching ability or none threads in
general is kind of up to you but even in
isolation this is just a very strong and
useful technique
at 18 we have something that many people
might think is a little bit higher up
but i'm putting phaeton's rising sun
here while there is usually something to
be said about versatility in general
sometimes a flaming spirit bomb of
destructive power is all you really need
the more damage that phaeton has taken
the more powerful rising sun is the
downside being that while this is strong
enough to vaporize enemies it could also
affect himself if he wasn't in his armor
this also goes for any of his friends or
allies nearby between the possibility
that this can easily go wrong and the
very straightforward one kind of use
this ability has it's just unfortunate
that it can't go higher up again much
like machi if we're taking into
consideration the rest of phaeton's
abilities specifically through pain
packer he has the potential to do a lot
more we've only really seen one or two
forms of pain backer so really who knows
what else he can do but for now rising
sun is falling into 18th
at number 17 we have an incredibly
powerful ability in crolo lucifer's
bandit secret honestly due to their
similarities it was between including
bandit secret or marowim's aura
synthesis i think as a general ability
horosynthesis is probably dozens of
times stronger however it's kind of
wasted on meruem it allows him to absorb
the nen of those that he eats adding it
to his own power but the thing is
maduem is already basically unlimited
when it comes to nen and he's already
much stronger than really anyone else in
the series the only effort that he
really had to put in for his fight with
netero was keeping his opponent alive
and like who else is really going to
compete with him at that point the best
example i can give for what i mean here
is it's kind of like if you gave the
rock steroids before he took part in an
arm wrestling tournament against
preschoolers like yeah sure it'll help
but
why
so if his ability could be given to
anyone in general sure but because it's
on meruem i don't think it's very
valuable actually instead we're going to
go with bandit secret by going through a
very complicated list of limitations and
procedures chrollo is able to steal the
net abilities of living people and store
them within his book he can use up to
two of these abilities at once but once
the person has died they're removed from
the book while this can be very very
strong it's honestly more about the
versatility this offers the obvious
downside is that there are so
so many limitations involved in getting
the new abilities using them and keeping
them because if the person dies it's
gone even with those limitations
considered though it definitely helps
krillo be much more efficient much more
effective and it definitely fits his
character very well as he leads the
phantom troop using their abilities for
his will and bandit's secret is just
kind of that embodied as nen with that
said though like i said earlier if you
feel that aura synthesis is better for
this list i totally get it number 16
goes to one of the most interesting
abilities i've ever seen in anime with
knuckles apr
once knuckle manages to make contact
with an enemy he can place this adorable
little guy on them and give them some of
his own aura from here apr will keep a
counter of how much aura they were given
as well as how much interest has accrued
every 10 seconds the amount owed is
increased by 10 percent quickly ramping
up until paying it back is actually
impossible at which point they hit
bankruptcy from here apr will transform
and for the next 30 days the target will
be unable to use nen unless apr is
removed furthermore until apr actually
transforms the person that it's attached
to is unable to deal damage to knuckle
and instead will only be paying off
their interest with each hit that said
the amount of damage they would have to
actually do to pay back all of the aura
quickly gets out of hand i really like
this ability because it's very easy to
set up and its only limitation is buying
time on top of that it's just super
clever and unique and very effective and
i absolutely love it number 15 is one i
find extremely creepy being illumi's
needle people by sticking needles into
the head of a person and then giving
them an order illumi is able to create a
more or less zombie which works for him
until they die or complete a task he can
also put a second needle in the person
to make them more capable being able to
speak or drive things like that however
the true value of this is the sheer
number of people he can implant this in
this isn't exactly a one person type of
thing and instead he can create an
entire army if he wants to and making an
army of zombie slaves is a pretty solid
ability of course just like machi and
phaeton which i'm picking up a theme
with the phantom troupe members illumi
can also do a few other things with his
needles if he wants which aren't really
being taken into consideration here
things like disguising himself for
example they do offer a pretty wide
variety of abilities but for right now
we're only focusing on needle people
specifically at 14 we have bona lenov's
battle canterbile now bona lenov's body
is kind of unique in that it has holes
scattered entirely throughout it these
holes are very useful for him though as
while he dances and moves throughout a
battlefield wind will start blowing
through them and music will be made this
music has some very diverse effects on
his environment for example he can
conjure up some warrior garb and a spear
but more iconic for his character i
think is the ability to create a
miniature jupiter to crush whoever is in
earshot of him fighting an enemy who's
using sound as a weapon is incredibly
hard to avoid and when they can drop a
mini planet on you just because you
heard them
you're probably not in a great spot
while this ability isn't the most flashy
or most complex thing in the world it is
surprisingly effective for what it is
at number 13 we have a chimera ant royal
guard with shayapoof and his beelzebub
this is just kind of a very useful and
versatile ability the basics of it allow
pouf to break down into many
many mini versions of himself really
getting as small as he'd like to however
at the point where he becomes smaller
than a fly he is no longer able to see
all of these mini versions of himself
are still controlled by himself
simultaneously and very much a kind of
hive mind mentality on top of that if
any of them are destroyed by physical
force they can just be reformed that
said if they are destroyed by something
like fire or electricity the healing
isn't really an easy process if it can
happen at all this ability can be used
to overwhelm opponents purely through
numbers escape from traps or cages dodge
attacks or spy on enemies just the wide
range of options that this offers
especially in someone in chiapoo's role
is an invaluable tool for the character
kite's crazy slot is our number 12 which
basically turns him into mr game and
watch from smash bros a roulette spins
granting him a number between 1 and 9
giving him a random weapon associated
with that number we have seen that to
include a scythe a mace and a gun
however we have 6 other forms we don't
really know about each of these weapons
is very powerful and kite is a master
with all of them making this a very good
mix of versatility and power the
downside of this is that obviously it is
still very random so despite the fact
that kite is a master with each one of
these tools individually some are better
suited to situations than others just by
design in the majority of cases though
he should be pretty fine as long as
there aren't any cats around and our
final chimera ant royal guard is yupi
coming in at our number 11 spot his rage
incarnate ability allows him to finally
be able to focus and control his anger
and power up until he had this
transformation he would basically
rampage chaotically yupi's destructive
power is unbelievable but he typically
can't really control it however in this
situation he nearly perfects himself
granting him more control over his
transformations strengths and rage
blasts while this ability is kind of
straightforward and just a direct power
up it works very well for his character
as it fixes all the issues that he
previously had and an ability that fills
in all the holes of your combat flaws is
very very useful now breaking into the
top 10 is what is said to be the
ultimate 1v1 ability
with hulkenberg's possession arrow this
is unfortunately a manga only ability
hulkenberg uses his subordinates aura to
produce both immensely powerful armor
and an arrow the arrow is possessed by
his subordinate spirit and will exist
until it lands on the target on top of
this it flies at incredible speeds that
are nearly impossible to dodge and has
enough power behind it to pierce any
armor or none ability in general this
ability supplies him with both top tier
defense and offensive abilities and just
based on these stats alone it kinda has
to be top 10 for me number nine is one
which might surprise you but it is nov's
hide and seek it might not be the most
deadly ability but the utility that this
offers and the ability to create a
pocket dimension with multiple sections
to it is just about as good as you can
get he can hold a large number of people
inside and doors can be set up ahead of
time making this essentially a secret
tunnel that for the most part cannot be
detected which i don't know if you're
trying to fight a war against chimera
ants would be a great way to get into
their territory it's good for hiding
mobility storage and so much more that
there are very few abilities in the
series that offer utility and
versatility in the way that hide and
seek does honestly the only downside of
hide and seek is that it takes this
ability's name away from jing who you
know as an awful father hides from his
seeking son number eight we have another
manga entry with morena's contagion if
you thought needlepeople was strong this
is kind of that on steroids using her
saliva she can infect up to 22 people to
take part in a game as these infected
people kill they will level up a certain
amount based on who or what they killed
gaining aura and at level 20 they will
even develop a new nen ability once
these people hit level 100 they will all
become able to spread this infection to
others essentially turning this into a
giant pyramid scheme
being able to produce nen abilities on
such a large scale as well as having an
ability herself that can spread to so
many people gives her so much potential
that i think number eight is pretty
reasonable number seven is my personal
favorite on the list and it's our second
last manga entry but unfortunately it
comes with a name that is very difficult
to say prince zaridnich has parallel
future
with this he can close his eyes and
instantaneously see the next 10 seconds
of time he can keep his eyes closed to
continue the vision but it will only
progress at normal speed from there so
he will always be 10 seconds ahead after
he uses this ability time will progress
normally for everyone else however he is
able to change his actions to better
suit the situation and no one will
notice those changes until time is
caught up effectively meaning that for
10 seconds he functionally can move
outside of time while everyone else
continues on like nothing has changed
this could make him a jojo's villain it
is absolutely crazy how strong this
ability is it allows you to move without
being noticed see the future to dodge
upcoming threats and even attack your
opponents without them knowing about it
for a few seconds number six goes to
benjamin's baton belonging to benjamin
and he's our last manga ability with
this benjamin is able to inherit the net
abilities of his private army when their
original users die this is kind of like
a much more free and useful version of
crollo's book while actually adding to
his power in a way that matters unlike
with meruem this ability seems like it
has unlimited potential to gather
abilities under the condition that
members of his personal army die but
like
they are soldiers so the likelihood of
that happening is pretty reasonable
while the downside of this ability is
having to wait for someone else to die
the upside is that it never seems to
fade away unlike in crolo's situation we
are starting off our top 5 with what is
probably the most famous ability in the
series offering more utility versatility
and functionality than just about any
other and incorporating creativity in a
way that very few other abilities do
hisoka's bungee gum which holds the
power of both rubber and gum can bounce
back projectiles sling objects act as a
bungee to draw enemies in repel himself
glue himself to the ground to give him
leverage pull back weapons that he has
thrown stop his own bleeding temporarily
reattach missing limbs bring himself
back to life by resuscitating his own
heart and lungs launch himself forward
towards enemies or back away to escape
and that's like not even half of it this
ability really is only limited to
hisoka's creativity in a way that
nothing else in the series really is
and despite its simplicity on the
surface it is one of the most powerful
and useful abilities available due to
how many options actually are presented
our number four could honestly be
swapped with bungee gum but here we have
kurapika's emperor time this is kinda
like karapika's version of gon's
transformation it's an ability that
drastically increases his own
performance at the cost of his own life
the major difference here being that
krapikas only costs him one hour of life
for every second in this mode so it
works out to about one week of his life
every three minutes of use
while this is still
a lot of time to lose it is very
different context for the character
using it gone is this bright and joyful
person with a lust for life and kurapika
really doesn't care what happens to
himself as long as he can get revenge on
the phantom troop while in most cases i
would say this is way lower on the list
purely based on the cost in karnataka's
specific situation i think it is totally
reasonable so what does the ability
actually do well emperor's time raises
the force and accuracy of all nen
categories while keeping the level the
same
basically it allows him to make
proficient use of every type of nen even
if he doesn't have much expertise now
it's important to note that it doesn't
make you a master of that category it
only boosts your performance at your
current level this is super complicated
to explain
and unfortunately the best way i can
actually represent it is with a pokemon
reference
so imagine you have a level 30 pichu
using emperor time basically boosts that
to a level 30 raichu you aren't going to
level 100 but your performance will
still be drastically improved i hope
that makes sense this is genuinely the
best i can do moving into our top 3 i
promise there will be no more pokemon
references we have what is probably
unanimously one of the strongest
abilities in the series with netero's
bodhisattva while it is mostly immobile
it allows for devastating sets of
attacks with near endless patterns and
incredible speed anyone other than
meruem probably wouldn't have been able
to deal with this because it's just so
oppressive the only weakness that this
ability has is that netero has an
unconscious tendency to rely on specific
patterns and meroem picked up on it
furthermore anyone other than netero
probably wouldn't have been able to make
full use of the technique due to the
speed required to actually use it
efficiently in netro's hands though it
is easily very high up on everyone's
list and i think you'd be crazy not to
have it in your top five with that said
though i can understand people putting
it as low as number five based on the
restrictions of immobility the need for
speed and the size of the ability
regardless though without question this
is a devastatingly powerful then ability
our runner-up is probably going to
surprise a lot of people but morel's
deep purple takes this easily to me and
to be honest it is kind of the last fair
entry in this list this ability is
probably the only thing with more
versatility than bungee gum and along
with that versatility it also adds a lot
of complexity all of deep purple's
abilities revolve around smoke which
morel can manipulate however he wants he
can make items such as ropes plants like
grass
animals like rabbits or even people who
are capable of speech and who are
individually very strong and fast as
well on top of that he can change its
color and camouflage it into its
surroundings he can make them as durable
as they need to be to the point where
they're almost indestructible or he
could make up to 216 dolls by spreading
his aura very thin but he can also make
that number much smaller to make much
stronger smoke people just the range and
possibility that comes with this ability
is phenomenal there is no real
restriction on it you're able to create
whatever you want and for as subtle as
an ability as it is it just kind of
dominates any situation you might find
it in for the versatility possibility
and just overall usefulness of this net
ability in every situation it has to be
my runner-up and our number one
is nanika's wish granting i can totally
understand people putting this a bit
lower as nanika themselves is kind of a
strange existence with their own set of
rules however to me this is just on a
different league nanika can take control
of alaka to grant one wish for someone
and there is likely no limit to what she
can do for example she can make people
float teleport them to another continent
and she was even able to remove the
condition of gone's transformation and
heal him it really doesn't stop there as
kilauea even explains that there's
probably nothing she can't do the cost
of this wish is the next person that
alika requests something to has to
complete three tasks for her even if
they are completely separate of the
situation entirely if the requests are
declined four times
other people will die as a result with
the minimum being two people being the
person that alika is making a request to
and the person that they love most both
of them will instantly be crushed to
death following that more and more
people will die depending on the size of
the previous wish those people are
decided based on who has spent most time
with the person alika is requesting
things to even if they aren't good
friends these people will all be wrung
out to death on top of all that killua
has his own ability to offer commands
rather than wishes which have their own
set of conditions that are much lighter
while the possible backlash is
definitely something to consider i mean
the ability to warp reality and fulfill
any wish without the wisher paying the
cost directly is probably something that
is impossible to really rank fairly the
only real restriction on nanika is that
she needs to take control of alaka and
that she can't make wishes for herself
but outside of that unlimited power and
possibility are kind of on the table and
that's why she's my number one
and there you have it my opinion on what
are the 20 best nen abilities throughout
hunter hunter
obviously this is kind of subjective as
nen
is very very tricky again this is not
just based on pure power but how useful
it is how much versatility it offers
stuff like that is also being taken into
consideration regardless of that though
i think that it's pretty hard to argue
that any of these abilities aren't
insanely powerful and amazing in their
own rights though but if you think that
some of them should have been higher or
lower or maybe some other abilities
should have made this list be sure to
let me know down in the comments because
i would love to see some of your takes
on different then abilities and again if
you would like to see a video on the top
20 nen users then let us know that as
well if you enjoyed this video though
and want to see more hunter hunter
content in the future on this channel
remember to leave a like and if you're
new to anime uproar remember to
subscribe and ring that bell by
selecting all notifications you can help
guarantee that you will not miss any
videos in the future and of course you
can always follow anime uproar at anime
uproar on twitter and instagram or you
can follow myself at excellionyt i want
to give a big thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thanks to
alpha sigma who is an absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twego himself and
of course are the one tier patrons the
ones who rise above all other clans
these being ingrada pate heffa al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted chi the
spike 8227 dylan isadore spidey life
tennelle tungsten tarcus baked buddhist
and monkey d quilly and finally thank
you to all of our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only gilgamesh the
red-haired raven angel crews rathuen de
ora very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia ted not ted fatboy games
corey mcgowan and soul ray slice and
dice if you enjoy our videos and feel
like they provide some kind of value to
you please consider checking out our
patreon through the link in the
description anyone who supports the
channel with even a single dollar has
access to our exclusive patreon only
discord and your name will appear at the
end of videos just like all of these
phenomenal people but for now i want to
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time remember to stay active
[Music]
you